so last night  on twitter luca doncic was trolling his  good buddy jj breast we learned the  details from adrian rojanowski of espn  of what the rules will be when the  players get tickets  for their family to come after the first  round lucas jj good because you know  they're only allowing people 32 inches  in below but the  trolling didn't end on twitter it  carried over to pregame  hey  [Music]  yo english english only hey and english  only in the bench all right  it's funny no no not spanish because  bobby is not good in spanish  ladies and gentlemen the dallas  mavericks  oh boy bobon and luca had jj in like a  straight jacket  oh man those are those are three buddies  right there